[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight for months now
privately we've been searching for a
meaningful definition of the word
equity we've consulted linguists we've
dusted off mouldering reference books
we've scoured the four
corners of god's own internet all in an
effort to figure out what
equity is we've done this not for
pleasure we have hobbies
but because we feel it's our duty as a
news program equity is now the
organizing principle of the united
states of america
on the very day he was inaugurated joe
biden signed executive order 13 985
that order makes equity mandatory across
the federal government and
all the agencies and yet strangely
neither joe biden or anyone else in the
administration has ever defined the word
so what is equity well tonight finally
we know what it is
equity it turns out is racism it's as
simple as that
equity is racism and to be clear we
don't mean racism in the sense that ice
cream and shakespeare and math are all
now supposedly racist
or that dr seuss is now considered an
exalted cyclops in the ku klux klan
we're not talking about the ilhan omar
atlantic magazine definition of racism
which by the way isn't actually language
but just another blunt political weapon
no we mean racism in the literal sense
in the way that martin luther king
defined the term which is the act of
hurting some people and helping others
purely on the basis of their respective
races
bigotry in other words prejudice hatred
that's what equity is
we know this thanks to lori lightfoot
the mayor of chicago
earlier today lightfoot released a
two-page manifesto defining equity quote
equity and inclusion are the north stars
of this administration
lightfoot explained then she got
specific about it
quote on the occasion of the two-year
anniversary of my inauguration as mayor
of this great city
i will be exclusively providing
one-on-one interviews with journalists
of color
so in the name of equity lori lightfoot
is refusing to grant interviews to white
people
like foot took pains to explain she
doesn't mean that personally
in fact she conceded that some of the
white reporters who cover city hall in
chicago
are talented and hardworking but
unfortunately they
are lightfoot said quote white
nonetheless
so there it is as plainly as anyone has
ever said it out loud white people are
disqualified because they are white
not because of anything they have done
or said or think
lori lightfoot doesn't care about that
she says so
lightfoot is not interested in what
these white people might be like as
individuals as people
she doesn't even care what kind of white
they are their ancestors could be from
italy or luxembourg or finland or spain
they could be members of the british
royal family they could be penniless
romanian immigrants living in a box on
the sidewalk on michigan avenue
rich or poor it doesn't matter to lori
lightfoot to lori lightfoot
all that matters is the fact they're
white because all white people
are the same they are entirely defined
by the color of their skin
you can see how this makes life a little
easier for lori lightfoot
she knows who to hate just by looking at
them
if someday the chicago police round up
the entire population of the city
lori lightfoot would have no trouble
pulling the right ones out of line for
punishment
by the way in case you're wondering yes
that was a nazi reference
it was deserved lori lightfoot is a
monster any society that allows
politicians to talk like this has a
very ugly future ahead very ugly
but of course no one said much at all
about what lori lightfoot said
in her manifesto even chicago reporters
some of whom could no longer do their
jobs
purely because of how they were born
offered only tepid complaints
listen to this person from nbc
another reporter called and said hey i'm
hearing they're only talking to black or
brown journalists and i said
what i it doesn't even sound real
and so i reached out to the
communications director
kate leffergy and she texted me back
and said yeah that's that's true she
said uh no
white reporters have been uh in the room
for the majority of the year and it's
time to hear from other people
what can this be real what you just
heard was confusion but not outrage
and yet there's nothing confusing about
who laurie lightfoot
is lori lightfoot is a dangerous bigot
lori lightfoot is hurting other people
because of their race
that's the crime but of course it's the
one thing nobody wants to say out loud
here's the response from a reporter at
the chicago tribune quote i'm a latino
reporter whose interview request was
granted for today
however i asked the mayor's office to
lift its condition on
others and when they said no we
respectfully canceled
politicians don't get to choose who
covers them end quote
talk about missing the point completely
and by the way of course politicians can
choose who they talk to
all of us have that right thank god
what politicians cannot do under any
circumstances
is an attack an entire group of citizens
on the basis of their skin color
again to restate the obvious that is
racism it is immoral it is also illegal
under countless state and federal laws
we are not supposed to allow behavior
like that from our government
we are all equal in the eyes of law we
are all citizens
we've got an entire granite monument on
the national mall in washington
promising that we will never behave that
way again we will never allow it
but because we've embraced equity we're
not simply allowing it we are
encouraging it
meanwhile house chicago the city of
chicago under lori lightfoot is
crumbling
murders last year jumped to 50 percent
hundreds more dead many of them young
people
children most of them black is that
social justice no it's not it's no one's
definition of social justice
not surprisingly lori lightfoot doesn't
want to talk about it
there are 50 members of the city council
in chicago they're called aldermen
one of them an alderman called raymond
lopez has repeatedly pressed laurie
lightfoot to explain
what she's doing to the city you should
know that raymond lopez is not a right
winger he's a democrat
he represents the 15th ward which is
overwhelmingly non-white
in some places it's impoverished but
raymond lopez cares a lot about his
constituents
so in january he raised an obvious point
with the mayor maybe
crime is shooting up in chicago because
chicago is a sanctuary city
is not enforcing federal law how did
lori lightfoot respond to this
she called him a racist being an
immigrant
or a refugee is not a
crime alderman napolitano and alderman
ray
lopez i just have to say shame
on you spirited debate which is at the
heart
of our democracy is not the same as
using
racist tropes and xenophobic rhetoric
to promote yourself on the backs of
others
and demonize them
calling for an elected official to
follow federal law is now a racist trope
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else